في تعقيب نستطيع ان نقول انه استباقي
اليوم من هنا مليار نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني تحدثت فيه بشعار الحرب لا تخلو
من الخسائر هذا الحديث جاء تعقيبا على ما
ياتي من اخبار بشان خسائر القوات
الاوكرانيه في الجبهات قالت ان الحرب تدور
في بعدين بعد حقيقي عسكري وبعد اعلامي
وهنا نوهت ان هناك مبالغه كبيره وفق
التقدير الاوكراني في هذه الاعلانات التي
تاتي متعلقه بخسائر القوات الاوكرانيه على
الجبهات مشيره الى ان المصدر الوحيد لهذه
المعلومات المعتمد هو القوات الاوكرانيه
ذاتها وبالتالي تحت تحدث بشكل اساسي عن
حرب معنويه تحاول
عزيمه الجيش الاوكراني وفق ما تقول نائبه
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني بشكل اساسي وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن ان هجماتها ما
زالت في سياق هجومي والتركيز اكثر على
الجبهه الشرقيه اذا اردنا ان نكون اكثر
دقه الحديث عن باخموت التي الحديث عنها
منذ ايام بتاكيد من قبل وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه والقوات الاوكرانيه ان السياق
الهجومي هناك مستمر والحديث عن استعاده
مساحات على على جبهات عده او في مناطق عده
في تلك الجبهه تحديدا هذا الموضوع المتعلق
موت ينسحب على مناطق اخرى يتم الحديث فيها
عن تصعيد سياق هجومي ايضا للقوات
الاوكرانيه في زبولوجيا مثلا لكن الحديث
ايضا عن السياقات الدفاعيه المتعلقه في
خرسون المتعلقه في جبهات اخرى تلتزم
القوات الاوكرانيه بهذا السياق الدفاعي
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه تتحدث بشكل دائم
عن طلعات جويه مكثفه نتحدث عن عدد متزايد
بالامس تم الحديث عن عشرين طلعه جويه
تحاول قصف معدات ومراكز التزويد الخاصه
بالقوات الروسيه وقد تم نشر بعض هذه الصور
بشكل اساسي اليوم وفي الامس تتحدث القوات
الاوكرانيه عن انها تحاول منع
القوات الروسيه من التمركز في نقاط عديده
من الجبهه ودفعهم اكثر فاكثر عن خطوط
القتال شكرا لك عدنان موريني مراسل
الجزيره كنت معنا من كييف